the countdown is on for all things
holiday and joining us to share his
holiday
must-haves is our friend entertaining
expert
paul zahn i always love what you bring
to the table
paul what do we need to have in our
arsenal for the holidays this year
well first up from holiday decor to
fashion to gifts
jcpenney has everything you need for
everyone on your list
at great prices we're also doing
contactless curbside pickup
so you can get some gifts like we have
some lush
fun throws we have a flannel for dad and
then also for mom why not get her a
sweater
in a matching one for fido at jcp.com
what do you think of that oh my gosh
that is so adorable
i i could seriously not only see myself
buying that sweater but
even though the flannel was for dad i'd
wear that too that's so cute
exactly and speaking of dad i have a
great gift for dad or mom we have
diageo's 2020 distillery edition
modeling of six very special single malt
scotch whiskies
this is going to give you a rare and
complex taste into these
wonderful whiskeys that everyone is
going to love
it's a perfect gift for anyone and the
the superior craftsmanship that goes
into these
liquids is amazing they're aged in wine
casts so
this is a great gift for anybody i'd get
it for my boo and we'd have some
chocolate do a chocolate
and scotch pairing and i think that
sounds like fun what do you think
yeah i think especially on those cold
nights maybe
throw a little of that in your tea or
something it's a perfect
drink to warm you up i love that idea
and now that we have something to drink
we're gonna need some food
and home chef dot com is taking all the
guessing work out of holiday meals this
year 2020 meals and holiday meals might
look a little different
but home chef has you covered these
bundles are available at homeshaft.com
or head to smith's and just pick it up
and what it is is it's heat and eat it
has the wonderful size it has a protein
it even has dessert so let's chat about
the sides a little they have a loaded
mashed potato with bacon we have
caramelized onion and green bean
and it really can take the guessing work
out so you can spend more time
with your family drinking and you can
wear dad's flannel what do you think
about that
i i really love that and i'll be honest
i've used those before and the great
thing about them
is that you can warm them up and then
place them in your own dish and people
think you spent
hours slaving in the kitchen on those
things exactly exactly when people
say oh who made this i go home chef and
they they don't know any better and
speaking of cooking
i have a great i have a great dessert
for you
i did a pumpkin parfait here with some
pumpkin greek yogurt and we're using
some truvia
sweet complete it's made from the stevia
leaf it's zero calorie
it's sort of a better for you option
because i'm gonna eat all these sides
but i'm gonna use truvia
to have a better for you dessert right
that looks
delicious you really have it all covered
on
all our bases thank you so much paul for
more information
just visit paulson.com we'll also share
all of this information on our social
media